[Musique]
d'accord
ce
[Musique]
mettre de la couleur dans un espace à
gré cl ça apaise sablettes des esprits
c'est vraiment selon tous bêtes 7 5
c'est un concept très basique tu met de
la couleur dans un quartier qui est
difficile les gens ils apprécient le
travail les enfants grandissent avec des
couleurs avec un esprit un peu plus
coloré
ça change un peu la clinique d'un espace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à rachid kisri demi le complexe
gnl ici à rimouski 12e une tenue très
loin tradis balla diakité n'diaye gadoue
la matière elle qui a gêne les tabous
très louche a dit saleh les tradi me
chauffer et s'éclairer
[Musique]